y
[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
colombia ha entrado en su cuarta semana
de paro nacional que inició el pasado 28
de abril con masivas movilizaciones que
continúan en las calles de todo el país
desde el gobierno colombiano de iván
duque se reúne con los miembros del
comité nacional del paro para negociar
una salida a la crisis que atraviesa el
país las condiciones del comité y los
manifestantes en las calles pasan por el
cese de la violencia policial contra los
manifestantes que dejan decenas de
muertos y miles de heridos para hablar
de estos temas nos acompaña wilson ruiz
ministro de justicia de colombia señor
ruiz muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 en medio del
diálogo tanto el comité nacional del
paro como los manifestantes en las
calles muchos que no se sienten
representados por el comité ponen como
condición primaria para las
negociaciones el cese de la violencia
policial contra los manifestantes qué
avances hay respecto a estas demandas y
otras peticiones del comité
a todos los televidentes de france 24 y
a toda la comunidad internacional
muchísimas gracias primero que todo
quiero decirte que una de las políticas
del señor presidente de la república
aquí en colombia iván duque es
precisamente que las marchas pacíficas o
no violentas son bienvenidas en colombia
desde que empezaron a estar marcha el 28
de abril infortunadamente se han
mezclado grupos delincuenciales grupos
de narcotraficantes en miembros del
ejército liberal de liberación nacional
ln es un grupo guerrillero que todavía
opera acá en colombia esto es lo que ha
generado a generar una violencia sin
límites aquí en colombia afortunadamente
decirte que hasta el momento en lo que
va corrido de estos días de paro se han
presentado 4.722 concentraciones mil 874
marchas 2.284 bloqueos 516
movilizaciones y 18 asambleas
decirte también que ha habido afectación
a la población civil y resulta que sean
actualmente hay quienes relacionados con
la protesta hay 11 en proceso de
clarificación y de terminación se han
sido en el marco de la protesta y marina
hay mil cuarenta civiles lesionados y
hay dos uniformados de la fuerza pública
fallecidos y hay mil 41 uniformados
lesionados que quiero decirles con esto
que hay más lesionados uniformados en
los mismos civiles entonces aquí en
colombia desde luego la democracia sigue
funcionando la política señor presidente
republicano ha dado instrucciones de que
los que la ha designado para
solucionarse del paro nacional no nos
podemos levantar de la mesa hasta que
nos lleguemos a un acuerdo desde luego
el cese de las protestas violentas sería
lo ideal para poder avanzar en este
proceso de llegar más fuerte
ministro qué tanta representación tienen
estos grupos ilegales en las protestas
cuando la sociedad civil en su
diversidad está en las calles
marina te recuerdo que apenas llevamos
26 días de protestas estamos a próximos
45 de completar el mes el 28 de este mes
decirte que efectivamente si hay una
inconformidad de parte de muchas
personas porque afortunadamente este
gobierno ha corrido con un problema
problemática de otros gobiernos
anteriores pero lo que sí te quiero
decir que la manifestación en colombia
son bienvenidas siempre hemos respetado
porque es un fundamento constitucional
es decir está entre nuestra constitución
de que la gente puede marchar de forma
pacífica y tranquila el gran problema
que nos afecta aquí en colombia son los
bloqueos porque porque en mi caso
particular sea presidente república me
ha delegado para que ellos en varias
regiones del país como el eje cafetero
como es el departamento del quindío
departamento de risaralda y departamento
del bayern y cada valle del cauca son
los más críticos en el paño estaba allá
constantemente hace más de tres semanas
decirte
hace unos días quemaron siete
tractomulas que traían medicamentos y
eso también se aprende a un problema
frente a la pandemia mira el día de ayer
hubo más de 21 mil contagiados y hubo
aproximadamente 500 muertos por el coi
porque se ha subido eso tremendamente el
informa la comunidad internacional
precisamente por culpa de las marchas
porque mucha gente no utiliza los
elementos de bioseguridad para poder en
cuidar de lo que está afectando
fundamentalmente al país en este momento
son los bloqueos muchos ciudadanos están
pidiendo claridad sobre las violaciones
de derechos humanos y la garantía de que
no quedarán impunes como condición para
el levantamiento de estos bloqueos
porque el gobierno no acepta la llegada
del cdh la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos o no le hace una
invitación para que este órgano venga a
colombia a hacer una verificación de lo
que está ocurriendo
me da marina es el presidente república
y todo el gobierno nacional jamás ha
impedido que a nuestro país ingresen
organismos de derechos humanos es más en
las reuniones que he tenido aquí en
colombia siempre nos ha acompañado a la
onu y también lo dije en días pasado y
lo iba a integrar nuevamente si la
comisión de derechos humanos la corte
americana derechos humanos desean
ingresar a nuestro país no le vemos
ningún inconveniente lo que te quiere
decir que aquí cualquier alto que se
esté cometiendo en contra de la
población civil está la fiscalía general
de la nación investigando y cuando está
inmerso algún miembro de la fuerza
pública aquí también está interviniendo
la procuraduría general de la nación en
cabeza de margarita cabello y la
fiscalía general de la nación en cabeza
de francisco barbosa están actuando
actualmente todo organismos de control
aquí todo está funcionando con base en
la democracia y desde luego repito esto
no tenemos ningún inconveniente que son
organismos para verificar los derechos
humanos a que nuestro país protección ha
sido muy importante marina en estos
momentos hay más de mil uniformados
lesionados
y te lo dije en 1.049 uniformados
lesionados y 1.040 civiles lesionados de
la marina tal vez la comunidad
internacional alcanza a ver esto pero
imagínate en días pasados un cai de la
policía habían días uniformados adentros
y le echaron candela e intentaron apunta
desde quemarlos vivos a ellos y el día
de ayer también quemaron otro joven otro
patrullero la policía que está en
cuidados intensivos de modo que la bolsa
pública también ha sido objeto de muchos
desmanes y muchos problemas en colombia
ministro pero las cifras son alarmantes
también del lado de los civiles de los
manifestantes cuántas denuncias por
abusos policiales manejan en este
momento y se están investigando a los
autores de estos crímenes
si marina quiero decirte que la cifra
que yo tuve como ministro de justicia
esté actualmente oficialmente hay 15
civiles fallecidos con la protesta y 11
están en proceso de clarificación y
determinación sanción en marco de la
protesta que te quiero decir con esto
que aquí en colombia de por si se
presentan muchos enfrentamientos con
delincuentes entre no podemos todos los
muertos que hayan constantemente sí que
es como consecuencia de la protesta de
sirte también marín ha abierto a la
comunidad internacional que como
ministro de justicia yo no permitiría
ninguna irregularidad no permitiría nada
diferente a que todo se asemeje dentro
de la legalidad que lo que ha explicado
el presidente republicano nueve
posiciones como ministro de justicia es
decirte que aquí tenemos que tener un
poco digamos de paciencia y seguir
avanzando por otro lado cabe mencionar
hace un momento los órganos de control
están funcionando muy bien lo que la
procuraduría y la contraloría aquí mira
por emprendidas pasados mencionar una
cantidad de gente desaparecida me fui de
cárcel en cárcel de nuestro país sobre
todo el departamento del valle del cauca
y empezaron a padecer mucha gente que
estaba retenida por parte de la fuerza
pública por los desmanes y delitos que
habían cometido entonces no nos puede
lanzar cifras sino que nosotros nos
sujetamos a todo lo que son los datos
oficiales sin solo instalar este momento
insiste un ministro hay múltiples
denuncias del uso desmedido de la fuerza
por parte de los policías para contener
las manifestaciones de en su mayoría
pacíficas como el polémico lanzador de
cohetes ven o no está el gobierno
dispuesto a escuchar una de las
principales demandas de los
manifestantes que es una reforma
policial inmediata
si marín a tu pregunta me gusta mucho
mirar estrategia que en colombia la
policía nacional tiene un grupo que
llama el smart en el que en este
momentos seguramente lo quiere saber él
es más un grupo que solamente actúa un
cuerpo que pertenece a la policía
nacional solamente actúa cuando un
momento de crisis es decir cuando las
marchas se salen de su conducto normal
cuando hay violencia en contra de la
población civil lo que te decía hace un
momento las infiltradas que se han hecho
aquí por parte de grupos irregulares
como narcotráfico y canarias del ln o
narcoterroristas en lo que está
generando esta violencia entre tanta el
smata contrarrestar por supuesto el
gobierno por lo menos está dispuesto a
escuchar todas las propuestas que hayan
pero en ningún momento desde el punto de
vista constitucional y legal se puede
eliminar a la policía nacional ni
tampoco tocar él es más repito propio es
un órgano que está creado precisamente
para responder frente a la violencia que
se genere por parte algunos
manifestantes
ahora decirte la gran mayoría de
manifestantes marina lo hacen
forma pacífica aquí lo que hay es un
grupo delincuentes pequeños que son los
que actúan actúan de momento se quitan y
vuelven nuevamente a generar este tipo
de causa en nuestro país
señor ministro el esmad fue creado
durante las épocas más cuentas de la
guerra en colombia con un fin muy
distinto a la represión vista ahora
contra los manifestantes durante las
protestas que reiteró en su mayoría son
pacíficas está o no el gobierno
dispuesto a escuchar esta petición de
reforma policial
y marina de lo que te acabo de explicar
a su momento el smata actúa solamente
con se presentan en motivos de crisis
con el problema en nuestro país el sma
funciona como lo ha hecho la policía en
francia cuando ocurren desmanes lo que
hacen es establecer el orden público eso
lo que pasa en colombia mira por ejemplo
hace 36 horas una ambulancia que
traslada al puerto de buenaventura valle
del cauca sa de la ciudad de cali una
bebé que estaba en crisis mira cómo se
murió porque no le dejaron pasar en un
bloqueo que derecha en forma
irresponsable entonces lo que esta causa
del desabastecimiento aquí la gente no
está infortunadamente consumiendo sus
alimentos no están vacunando contra el
cob y hay mucha gente como oculta de las
protestas la gente nos está alimentando
por culpa del desabastecimiento pero la
bolsa pública tiene que actuar porque
porque la garza más de 50 millones de
colombianos no podemos frente a unos
pocos entrar nosotros a que el país
entra en un caos completo ministro ruiz
nos quedamos sin tiempo pero me gustaría
hacerle una última
el presidente iván duque dijo
recientemente en una entrevista en
inglés que el senador y líder opositor
gustavo petro está detrás de las
protestas opinó este lo mismo
si infortunadamente marina que tú acaba
de necesidad sea el senador gustavo
petro infortunadamente está digamos
agitando las masas para generar un caos
aquí en colombia yo considero que
nosotros aquí en nuestro país tenemos
que siempre buscar la cordialidad buscar
el diálogo y la concertación para poder
nosotros finalmente por otra puerta qué
es lo que quieren los manifestantes
somos conscientes porque el presidente
de república en cuenta los jóvenes les
ha anunciado que al estrato 1 2 y 3 se
elevará educación no solamente
universitaria sino también técnica
entonces represente la república ha
hecho un gran convenio nacional con los
jóvenes precisamente que lector familiar
que hemos visto allí
ministro wilson ruiz muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 a
nuestra audiencia le invitamos a
continuar informados en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]
y